pour vous présenter notre note parue
enfin étudier ce matin à lopex sur le
recyclage des plastiques donc trois ans
après notre rapport sur la pollution
plastique Philippe bolo et moi-même
avons souhaité travailler sur ce
recyclage nous avions déjà abordé ce
sujet mais nous avons estimé que les
techniques évoluant rapidement il y
avait de quoi actualiser nos
connaissances dans ce domaine alors pour
commencer je vais vous présenter d'abord
les caractéristiques du recyclage tel
que on l'a en France actuellement et
vous redonner la définition du recyclage
tel qui figure dans la loi l'article L
541-1-1 du code de l'environnement mais
qui est très général puisqu'elle date de
quelques années il définit le recyclage
comme tout opération de valorisation par
lesquelles les déchets sont retraités en
produits matières ou substance au fin de
leur fonction initiale ou à d'autres
fins cela inclut le retraitement des
matières organiques mais suis pas la
valorisation énergétique la conversion
pour utilisation comme combustible ou
pour des opérations de rambblage cette
définition qui devra sans doute être
précisé ne distingue pas ce qu'on est en
train de regarder de plus près à savoir
le recyclage en boucle fermée alors la
boucle fermée c'est lorsque les déchets
recyclés vont être utilisés pour un
usage strictement identique c'est le cas
de la bouteille de PET qui servira à
refaire des bouteilles en put et le
recyclage en boucle ouverte dans le dans
lequel la matière recyclée est utilisée
pour une distination différente c'est le
cas si la bouteille en PET va finir en
tissu polaire il existe deux grandes
techniques de recyclage le recyclage
mécanique celui qui est actuellement en
vigueur dans 99% des cas les déchets
plastiques vous le savez sont collectés
triés pour obtenir des flux homogènes de
polymère ils sont broyés lavés retraité
et transformé en granulés pour être
réutilisé sous la forme de matière
plastique recyclée l'autre technologie
qui est en train d'émerger et le
recyclage chimique en réalité ce terme
très générique englobe de nombreuses
technologies différentes qui se sont
développées ces dernières années au
moins à l'état de projet et qui se
classe en trois groupes le premier
groupe c'est la purification à l'aide de
solvant elle vise à séparer puisque je
rappelle pour la bonne compréhension
qu'une matière plastique c'est un
polymère et puis les additifs et les
additifs qui peuvent être nombreux et
variés et donc c'est la séparation par
cette méthode là du polymère des autres
substances chimiques pigments
retardateurs de flammes et toutes les
substances qui peuvent être contenues
dans les plastiques
donc les déchets plastiques sont plongés
dans un bain solvant le polymère est
séparé des autres composants et une fois
que ce procédé de purification est
achevé le polymère est exposé à une
solution non solvante pour être à
nouveau solidifié donc ça s'appelle la
purification la deuxième méthode est la
dépoliérisation alors comme la base
d'une d'une matière plastique c'est un
polymère donc une longue chaîne carbonée
et bien il suffit de retrouver le
monomère et une fois que cette
dépoliérisation a eu lieu les moneymères
sont récupérés en vue d'être purifiés
également par distillation précipitation
cristallisation et il y a plusieurs
façons d'obtenir cette dépoliérisation
par voie chimique et dont le nom change
en fonction du solvant qu'on a utilisé
ça peut être de l'hydrolyse quand le
solvant et l'eau une méthanolyse quand
le selvant et le méthane etc il y a
également possibilité et ça a été
démontré par une société donc à
Clermont-Ferrand et des recherches qui
ont été faites sur ce sujet là une
dépoliérisation enzymatique qui vise à
briser ses chaînes cette longue chaîne
carbonée à l'aide d'enzymes donc voilà
cette deuxième façon de faire la
troisième c'est la conversion qui est
une dépolymérisation thermique qui
consiste à rompre les chaînes polymères
grâce à la pyrolyse ou de la
gazéification avec des températures
élevées de manière à les convertir en
liquide ou en gaz qui peuvent être après
utilisés comme matière première dans un
processus de raffinage conversion et à
nouveau possiblement polymérisation
alors quels sont les avantages attendus
du recyclage alors on a bien sûr les
avantages évidents qui s'inscrivent dans
une logique d'économie de la ressource
mais également de gestion durable des
déchets mais sont évoqués également que
le recyclage pourraient permettre de
limiter les gaz à effet de à effet de
serre actuellement
98,5% du plastique et d'origine fossile
et cette industrie représente 10,7% la
consommation de pétrole très clairement
le la matière plastique correspond
actuellement je vous le résume à 4,7%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
comparaison les outils numériques 3,5%
et le transport aérien à
3,8%. une étude réalisée en 2017 sur les
émissions de CO2 les économies d'énergie
liées au recyclage à montrer qu'une
tonne de PET recyclée permet très
d'économiser 70% de gaz à effet de serre
et 83% d'énergie par rapport à la
production d'une tonne de plastique
vierge le recyclage permettrait
également de réduire notre dépendance
vis-à-vis des importations d'énergie
fossile et de matière première tels que
le polyester par exemple pour les
textiles ou le caoutchouc naturel pour
les pneus je tiens néanmoins à préciser
que pour cela il faudrait qu'il y ait
des filières de recyclage en boucle
fermée des textiles ou des textiles en
polyester ou des pneus en France ce qui
n'est pas le cas la contribution du
recyclage à la lutte contre les déchets
et la pollution en plastique est
beaucoup plus mitigée s'agissant de la
production de déchets la proportion de
recyclage en boucle ouverte ainsi que la
limite physique à laquelle se heurte le
nombre de cycles de recyclage font de ce
dernier
simplement un amortisseur temporel de
formation des déchets puisque au bout de
quelques recyclages et ils sont limités
en nombre on obtient on finit par
obtenir un déchet quant à la pollution
plastique malheureusement elle ne se
limite pas à la gestion de la fin de vie
des plastiques mais concerne tous les
stades de leur cycle de vie de la
production jusqu'à
comprenant l'usage puis la fin de vie et
quand on parle pollution plastique il
faut également
entrevoir qu'il y a un problème de
relargage des additifs et tous les
autres plastifiants qui sont contenus
qui sont relargués en continu pendant
tout le cycle de vie de l'objet et la
dégradation possible en microplastiques
voire nanoplastiques je vais laisser la
suite
merci mesdames et messieurs maintenant
que le les grands principes
technologiques sont posés et que vous
avez une idée très claire de quoi il
s'agit lorsqu'on parle de recyclage la
note que nous avons réalisée elle pose
aussi à l'adresse aussi une question
c'est celle de est-ce que finalement le
recyclage des plastiques permet-il ou
contribut-t-il à l'économie circulaire
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail de
l'économie circulaire versus l'économie
linéaire partant du principe que vous
voyez tous de quoi il s'agit et la
répondre à cette question de le du rôle
du recyclage dans l'économie circulaire
dans le cas particulier des plastiques
et bien il y a différentes façons de
regarder le sujet la première façon
c'est de regarder les quantités
recyclées alors là déjà en examinant cet
angle là du sujet on se rend compte
d'une très grande variabilité des
données vous avez dû les uns et les
autres pouvoir observer c'est à dire
selon le secteur d'activité concerné on
a des taux de recyclage qui sont
différents différentes si on est dans
l'emballage par rapport au bâtiment on a
des évidemment et ça c'est assez logique
c'est aussi par rapport aux capacités on
a des recyclage qui varie selon les pays
et on a aussi des taux de recyclage qui
peuvent varier selon les méthodes c'est
à dire selon les chiffres qu'on compare
de Z2 est-ce qu'on va les regarder la
quantité totale de déchets comparer à la
quantité qui va rentrer dans une unité
de recyclage ou à la quantité de
produits recyclés qui va être
effectivement sorti de cette unité là
donc vous comprenez que cette grande
variabilité n'est pas à y voir très
clair malgré tout je vais essayer quand
même de vous donner quelques chiffres
pour poser des grandes tendances et les
grands ordres de grandeur de ce qu'est
le recyclage des plastiques vous
trouverez dans la dans la note des
chiffres de 2020 qui vous indiquent que
6,5 millions de tonnes de plastique ont
été consommés que en 2020 générant 3,76
millions de tonnes de déchets plastiques
alors là c'est déchets évidemment après
ils peuvent être préparés pour dire
recyclage arriver dans une des unités de
recyclage et faire l'objet de granulés
qui sont eux-mêmes recyclés la meilleure
façon de comptabiliser les choses c'est
de regarder cette quantité de granulés
recyclés par rapport
à les déchets qui étaient produits et en
faisant ça on arrive à un chiffre de
11,7% de taux de recyclage on peut lire
dans d'autres éléments de littérature
25% parce que parfois les méthodes ne
sont pas les mêmes je voulais vous
donner un autre chiffre qui suit le CDE
qui nous dit que 9 % niveau mondial du
plastique et recyclé donc retenons
l'ordre de grandeur de 10%. donc les
statistiques liées aux données sur les
plastiques et les déchets qui tiennent
compte ou non des exportations voyez
sont sensibles au mode de gestion à la
quantité de matière recyclées à la
nature des produits et en tout cas dans
le surface à des données dispersées
hétérogènes partielles et imprécise et
je vais rajouter un niveau de complexité
comme si j'en avais pas assez donné
jusqu'à l'or c'est que Angèle prévu vous
l'a clairement expliqué on a dû
recyclage en boucle ouverte ou en boucle
fermée et même cette notion-là est de
nature à introduire les différents
sensibles en matière d'interprétation
ainsi les bouteilles PET 17% sont
recyclés en bouteille le reste étant en
textile et barquettes donc vous voyez
que le chiffre de 17 est pas le même que
si on considère la totalité du côté
bouteilles recyclée donc répondre à
grande prudence les chiffres pour savoir
de quoi on parle et donc des chiffres
qui peuvent être trompeurs mais qui
révèlent un faible le taux de recyclage
malgré tout voilà ce qui est le premier
point répondre à la question c'est aussi
de se dire on a vu la difficulté à
quantifier le recyclage et de se dire
bah alors considérant ce qu'on a
effectivement recyclé regardons quelle
proportion rentre dans les produits que
nous fabriquons là aussi les chiffres
varient énormément
plusieurs chiffres 2021 8,3% des
plastiques fabriqués avec du recyclé en
Europe toujours en 2021 9,9% en France
en 2020 7,8 si je regarde uniquement les
emballages en Europe en 2021 8,5 je veux
pas vous inonder de chiffres mais je
vais vous faire la démonstration que là
aussi il faut être prudent par rapport
aux chiffres qu'on utilise mais quand
tous les cas vu l'ordre de grandeur des
données que je vous ai indiqué le
recours aux matières premières recyclées
pour la production de plastique ne
traduit pas aujourd'hui encore un
recours massif au recyclage pourquoi
toutes ces difficultés là parce que nous
sommes face à un certain nombre
d'obstacles qui peuvent être techniques
vous les connaissez la dégradation de
ces polymères au fur et à mesure des
cycles de recyclage mais aussi
quelque chose d'important c'est que la
plupart des polymères sont pas miscibles
entre eux et quand on considère cette
première donnée et le fait que c'est
polymère ils sont
innombrés parce que c'est des polymères
mélangés à des additifs et que dans le
nombre de formulations est très grand
mais le fait que ça ne se mélange pas et
encore une autre difficulté les
obstacles sont également réglementaires
vous trouverez dans la note des éléments
sur les substances hérités sur le sujet
du grade alimentaire et également
économique puisque le prix de des
matières vierges est malheureusement
souvent moins cher que celle que le prix
des matières recyclées puis on a aussi
un sujet qui est loin d'être négligeable
c'est que pour bien recycler il faut
avoir un gisement de qualité et
disponible donc ça veut dire qu'avant
même par les recyclages il faut parler
de capacités de tous les producteurs de
déchets à bien séparés les différents
flux de la collectivité souvent
lorsqu'il s'agit de nous-mêmes dans nos
habitations à être en capacité d'aller
venir collecter chez les habitants les
déchets et après les trier donc vous
voyez qu'on a toute une série d'étapes
de travail préparatoires qui
conditionnent la qualité de ce qu'on va
pouvoir recycler et donc la nature du
recyclage autre élément regarder le
sujet c'est de se dire malgré ses freins
mais en apportant consenti d'énormes
efforts en la matière des efforts
législatifs vous connaissez les
objectifs sur le recyclage qui ont été
donnés à la fois au niveau français
européen vous avez aussi les
investissements considérable qui sont
mis en place par les collectivités
territoriales l'État les écho-organismes
pour parvenir à la collecte au tri et
recyclage de manière efficace et
efficiente et puis on a aussi des
efforts de recherche qu'il ne faut pas
négliger dernier élément pour répondre à
cette question initiale que je vous ai
posée le recyclage contribue-t-il ou non
à l'économie circulaire et bien c'est de
se rendre compte que ce recyclage
aujourd'hui
il progresse moins vite que la
production de plastique et ne permet pas
de d'endiguer la production des déchets
je me réfère pour cela un rapport de
l'OCDE récent de 2022 qui nous montre
que en 2019 on a 353 millions de tonnes
de déchets plastiques et que selon les
projections faites par l'OCDE nous en
aurions 1041 millions tonnes en 2060
vous voyez le facteur de progression et
ce facteur de il a comparé aux facteur
du recyclage le CDE nous dit 9%
aujourd'hui 17% en 2060 on va bien nous
sommes en face de deux courbes qui
divergent et que le recyclage je
n'arrive pas à rattraper cette courbe de
l'augmentation de la pollution de la
production de plastique voilà et donc en
ayant dit ça derrière vous imaginez
qu'évidemment comme il y a des fuites et
ben les fuites vont aller dans les mêmes
proportions de manière plus grande en
2060 et l'accumulation a évidemment
accroître donc pour répondre à la
question initiale que je vous ai posée
et bien la réponse pour moi est la
suivante c'est que aujourd'hui le
recyclage ne permet pas l'économie
circulaire à lui seul et pas dans les
conditions qui sont les siennes
Actuellement je repasse la parole à ma
collègue sénatrice
merci Philippe nous allons maintenant
nous intéresser aux conditions
nécessaires pour mettre en place un
recyclage efficace d'abord il nous
semble qu'il nous faut éviter un certain
nombre de pièges nous en avons relevé 5
j'en présenterai deux le premier piège
est à éviter et l'inversion de la
hiérarchie de gestion des déchets tels
qui établit et tout le monde consent à
dire que c'est la bonne la bonne formule
qui est celle des trois R et en premier
le premier r C'est la réduction le
deuxième c'est le réemploi et ensuite
seulement après vient le recyclage
pourtant dans les faits les schémas
circulaires présentant le recyclage
donne l'illusion qu'il pourrait à lui
seul assurer la circularité de
l'économie des plastiques une telle
vision présente un double risque celui
de participer à la normalisation des
déchets c'est à dire que on ne va plus
faire attention parce que de toute façon
c'est tout va bien c'est recyclé mais
aussi celui de dissimuler ou de masquer
les alternatives à la consommation de
plastique en faisant croire comme l'a
évoqué Philippe avec ce qu'il vient de
vous expliquer qu'il est possible de
contrôler les déchets ce qui n'est pas
le cas actuellement et qu'il ne sera pas
visiblement dans le futur les discours
très volontaristes sur le recyclage
chimique censé recycler les déchets
plastiques contaminés et hétérogènes que
le recyclage mécanique ne peut pas
traiter donne l'impression de pouvoir
boucler la boucle alors que cette
technologie sont loin d'avoir démontré
leur capacité à recycler tous les
plastiques un coût financier et
environnemental acceptable le deuxième
piège à éviter et de tout miser sur les
solutions
technologiques afin de faire face à des
plastiques parce que voilà
la société et la suite là
la société la suivante c'est-à-dire
qu'on a laissé se développer depuis les
50 60 70 ans des formulations très
diverses et tout le monde qu'on a fait
ce qu'il voulait comme il voulait en
matière de production et d'usage et bien
maintenant il nous faut gérer ses flux
très hétérogènes donc on a amélioré pour
le coup pour s'adapter les techniques de
tri de recyclage entraînant des dépenses
croissantes et notamment comme l'a dit
Philippe tout à l'heure pour les
collectivités territoriales néanmoins
l'efficacité de cette course
technologique restera limitée sans une
action forte sur les deux autres leviers
d'amélioration du taux de recyclage que
sont la recyclabilité d'ailleurs il faut
se poser la question est-ce que c'est
recyclable donc pour l'instant on a
laissé faire pendant quelques années
mais maintenant on est au pied du mur et
il faut regarder les matières plastiques
mis sur le marché qui sont effectivement
recyclables et sur le tri des déchets je
vais laisser Philippe vous présenter les
deux des trois suivants alors s'agissant
des trois autres
pièges à éviter je vais commencer par un
premier en faisant référence aux
éco-organismes alors vous connaissez le
rôle central des écorces organismes
pierre angulaire du système de la
responsabilité élargie du producteur du
principe pollueur-payeur avec leur
mission de gestion des déchets et de
réduction de la quantité de déchets mais
il faut regarder ça attentivement il se
rendent compte que ces organismes ils
ont cette mission de dire il faut mieux
gérer les déchets et qui en est moins
mais ils sont quand même à la tête de
d'émetteur en marché donc là si vous
voulez il y a une injonction à un moment
donné qui peut paraître paradoxale entre
des metteurs en marché qui qui vont
orienter des choix qui seraient non non
conforme à ceux de leurs objectifs de de
commercialisation d'un certain nombre de
produits donc ça c'est un premier sujet
où on pourrait considérer qu'il y a une
sorte de risque de d'être un peu jugé
parti et puis il y a aussi une autre
façon de regarder le sujet c'est pour
être assez synthétique c'est de se dire
c'est un nouvel c'est il a un rôle
central les co-organismes mais à lui
seul il ne gère pas les déchets c'est à
dire qu'ils se rep sur des efforts
d'investissement considérables fait
notamment pour les collectivités
territoriales qui vont qui vont
s'occuper de la communication auprès des
habitants lorsqu'on parle d'eux de
l'équipement de ses habitants en
poubelle jaune de la collecte de ses
poubelles jaunes de là je suis donc sur
loyer les déchets ménagers de
l'extension de la consigne de tri ces
collectivités peuvent aussi mettre en
place des centres de tri pour aller
collecter autre chose qui peuvent être
des par exemple des anciens produits
électroménagers donc vous rendez compte
que finalement les forces financiers
l'effort sur le terrain il est fait par
la collectivité après on a des unités
les entreprises qui vont aller recycler
au milieu on a un peu ces éco-organismes
qui peuvent parfois concentrer un
certain nombre de gisements et du coup
avoir de part la nature de ceux qui qui
sont à prendre des décisions dans les
éco-organismes des choix qui parfois ne
pourraient pas être les meilleurs donc
pour toutes ces raisons là et nous
partageons l'idée et nous l'avons écrit
dans la note qui a un besoin et besoin
d'un suivi renforcé et d'un contrôle
renforcé également des écrous des
éco-organismes notamment par le
Parlement puisque c'est quand même nous
à un moment donné qui vautour un certain
nombre de règles qui s'appréciente aux
éco-organismes le piège suivant c'est
éviter que le recyclage chimique ne
s'impose au détriment du mécanique ce
qu'on regarde l'histoire on voit que le
mécanique était là on vous a clairement
expliqué qu'elle va certainement de
limites et le chimique est apparu comme
étant des solutions alternatives donc
qu'ils viennent en complément est une
chose qu'ils viennent en substitution
serait quand même assez différent
surtout que à l'heure actuelle on se
pose encore de très nombreuses questions
sur ce recyclage chimique je vous le
rappelle reste quand même des
technologies de laboratoire des
technologies expérimentales et encore
peu souvent des technologies
industrielles effectivement mises en
place sur le terrain donc on a
évidemment les questionnements liés à
l'impact de cette de ce recycler
chimique les questionnements sur le
devenir des substances chimiques en
dehors des polymères puisque le principe
est quand même des dépôt numériser de
revenir au monomère principe général il
y a quand même les additifs le sujet des
additifs que deviennent-ils et puis il y
a aussi aussi un vrai sujet de
traçabilité
donc ce qu'on dit si vous voulez dans la
nôtre c'est qu'à la qualité de recyclage
identique il vaut mieux privilégier le
mécanique aux chimique et puis aussi on
dit on écrit que finalement il est
soumis au même contrainte c'est à dire
que c'est bien quand même la qualité du
gisement qui veut déterminer la capacité
du recycle chimique à être efficient et
puis il peut induire aussi comme le
Russie clair mécanique des effets
verrous des effets rebonds sur lesquels
il faut être vigilant et le dernier le
cinquième piège à éviter alors
là on pouvait passer l'après-midi si
vous voulez je vais être très court
c'est la fameuse mise en place de la
consigne des bouteilles en télét alors
il s'avère que ce matin la dame a remis
le rapport de qui était attendu pour la
loi agg il a été remis ce matin je m'en
lira avec intérêt dès qu'on aura la
possibilité de l'avoir en gros de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit d'objectif vous le
savez qui sont 77% des collègues des
bouteilles en eau en 2025 et 90% 2029 en
France en 2022 on était à 60 donc on se
rend compte 60% on se rend compte des
des marches importantes à franchir donc
pour ça le principe de la franchise de
la de la consigne a été mise en place
mais alors quand on dit qu'on n'est pas
au rendez-vous des objectifs on peut se
dire bon ben après tout on n'est pas les
meilleurs élèves de la classe mais ça a
quand même des incidences financières
puisque je vous rappelle qu'il y a une
taxe européenne qui a été mise en place
ces pays par les 10 pays les plus riches
pour financer en partie les les aides de
gestion de crise covid et qu'elle
s'élève à 0,8 80 centimes d'euros par kg
de plastique non recyclé quand même ça a
coûté à la France
1,25 à peu près 1,247 milliards d'euros
en 2021 et des milliards d'euros à
l'époque où on est bien de tous les
gérer convenablement voilà donc le
modèle de consigne nous pose problème on
va pas rentrer dans un détail dans un
débat on verra évoquer ça pourrait nous
amener très loin mais en gros quels sont
les éléments qui nous permettent de dire
aujourd'hui que le modèle tel qu'il est
imaginé n'est pas le bon on n'est pas
contre la consigne c'est que ce soit
très clair mais c'est le modèle qui pose
question le premier élément c'est que
c'est une injonction contradictoire pour
les habitants concernés à qui on a dit
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mettez votre
poubelle votre bouteille dans la
poubelle jaune et demeure Landi faut
plus la mettre dans la poubelle jaune
c'est quand même un peu compliqué
ensuite il y a le modèle économique des
collectivités alors quand on dit ça nous
retord que c'est souvent pour ceux qui
sont fans de cette consigne là que c'est
juste un problème financier bon je vous
ai dit justement
l'amande alors effectivement si on a
plus l'amende à payer on pourrait
affecter l'argent ailleurs mais bon
c'est quand même de l'argent qu'on
dépense donc les sujets de du modèle
économique collectivité qui ont dépensé
pour pouvoir avoir les poubelles les
plastiques les bouteilles en PET et qui
pourraient pu les vendre parce qu'elles
n'ont plus la main sur ses bouteilles là
il y a aussi autre chose c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui si des acteurs
économiques sont en capacité de venir
chercher des bouteilles en PET de
manière sur des gisements importants
c'est parce que pendant plusieurs
décennies vous avez eu l'effort des
collectivités l'effort des citoyens qui
ont payé leur taxes au travers leurs
impôts pour mettre en place toute cette
infrastructure qui existe et donc ça
pose quand même question à un moment
donné en terme d'intérêt général de bon
usage de l'argent public de se dire
est-ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on fait bien
lorsqu'on investit de l'argent public
qu'au bout d'un certain temps il y a une
sorte de dévoiement et qu'une partie de
l'économie de ce de cet investissement
partent donc privé voilà ça c'est un
autre élément il y a l'effet verrou par
rapport aux bouteilles plastique
n'oublions pas que des mêmes
collectivités sont productrices d'eau
mettent beaucoup d'argent pour produire
de l'eau robinet qui est moins cher que
que l'on bouteille de très bonne qualité
donc on verrouille le comportement
d'utilisation des bouteilles en
plastique lorsqu'il s'agit d'eau et puis
avoir d'autres boissons à l'intérieur il
y a le sujet de la différence entre les
zones les collectivités territoriales
urbaines et rural quand on regarde les
objectifs souvent ils sont en zone
rurale et moins en zone urbaine donc le
problème de la non atteinte des
objectifs disons-le clairement c'est
aussi un problème parisien un problème
marseillais un problème lyonnais c'est
pas un problème en juin c'est pas un
problème de Cahors donc il faut aussi
savoir chacun prenne ses responsabilités
et puis dernier point c'est est-ce que
c'est véritablement de la consigne quand
vous achetez votre boisson dans une
bouteille en plastique et que vous payez
un peu plus cher et quand vous ramenez
la bouteille on vous redonne pas
l'argent vous avez donné en plus on vous
donne un bon d'achat dans une grande
surface est-ce que ça c'est
véritablement de la vraie consigne je
pose la question en posant la question
vous avez une idée de la réponse qui est
la nôtre je repasse la parole en gel qui
en ont parlé des recommandations
alors en conclusion nous allons vous
présenter les leviers pour améliorer les
taux de recyclage et favoriser le
recyclage de haute qualité premier
levier il faut définitivement inscrire
le recyclage dans une stratégie globale
de réduction de la production de
plastique le recyclage ne peut pas à lui
seul garantir la mise en place d'une
économie circulaire des plastiques ni
permettre à l'industrie plastique
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 il doit s'intégrer dans une
stratégie beaucoup plus large visant à
réduire notre consommation de plastique
et comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure la
question est bien celle du flux qui ne
fait que grossir et donc de la
production exponentielle de cette
matière là concrètement on ne va pas
arrêter de courir après le vieux numéro
2 améliorer la recyclabilité des
plastiques à travers la prise en compte
de leur recyclage dès leur conception de
nombreux outils pour évaluer la
recyclabilité des emballages ont été
développés aussi bien au niveau national
que européen il convient désormais de
les appliquer en rendant la mise sur le
marché de produits non recyclables
réellement dissuasive l'objectif est de
limiter le nombre de polymères
d'additifs et de standardiser les
emballages et d'éliminer les
perturbateurs de tri pour le
perturbateur de recyclage pour renforcer
l'efficacité de ce recyclage mécanique
tout en contenant les coûts levier
numéro 3 augmenter les performances de
la collecte avant de se lancer dans un
dispositif national de consignes pour
recyclage de nombreux leviers d'action
existent aussi bien en avant en amont
comme je l'ai dit avec la stratégie des
3R qu'en aval à travers l'amélioration
de la performance des collectes sur les
sélectives éventuellement l'accélération
du déploiement de la tarification
incitative même si il nous faudrait
peut-être revoir les modalités adoptées
jusque là parce qu'on voit que sur les
territoires il y a de l'inacceptabilité
de la chose des coûts plus élevés alors
que tout le monde trie et sa pause le
problème et enfin une meilleure
captation des gisements hors foyer et là
on a de grandes marges de manœuvre
au-delà du secteur des emballages
d'autres secteurs doivent également
améliorer leur performances en matière
de collecte levier numéro 4 donner la
priorité au recyclage mécanique par
rapport au recyclage chimiques dans les
appels d'offres tout en privilégiant un
recyclage de haute qualité car en dépit
des discours rassurants sur la
complémentarité entre ces deux
techniques de recyclage il existe un
réel risque de voir le recyclage
chimique se développer au détriment du
recyclage mécanique sous prétexte que
les matières issues de ce dernier
seraient de moindre qualité en réalité
un tri et une préparation de qualité des
matières à recycler permet très souvent
un recyclage mécanique en boucle fermée
à des coûts moins élevés et avec un
bilan environnemental plus favorable
qu'avec le recyclage chimique en outre
le renforcement indispensable des règles
en matière de recyclabilité devrait
faciliter le recyclage mécanique par le
développement de flux plus homogène et
bien sûr de la simplification des
formulations des plastiques ce n'est
qu'à cette condition que le recyclage
chimique sera réellement complémentaire
et non pas concurrent du recyclage
mécanique je laisse Philippe Termini
bien sûr pour terminer avec les
recommandations qui sont la note les
nôtres dans cette dans cette note
scientifique de l'OPEX une première qui
est très technique alors pour éviter de
rentrer dans le détail qui nous
amènerait sur des des notions assez
complexes je vais vous en donner les
l'esprit l'esprit est le suivant vous
devez vous demander de d'imaginer à
recyclage mécanique où vous avez en
entrée d'une chaîne de recyclage c'est
assez facile à imaginer vous avez une
chaîne linéaire vous mettez un produit à
l'entrée il est broyé il est nettoyé il
est fondu on fait des granulés à la
sortie donc une quantité qui rentre
donne une quantité qui sort et un
rendement et on imagine que tout ce qui
est là à l'entrée donne du recyclé à la
sortie ça c'est le mécanique dans le
chimique il y a des pertes d'importantes
perte mais dans le chimique c'est encore
plus compliqué parce que vous il y a une
technologie qui est celle de la pyrolyse
vous allez transformer vos objets
plastiques en une huile et donc celui et
cette huile vous imaginez bien que pour
qu'elle redonne les granulés il y a un
petit process quand même industriel
autour et ce process industriel c'est
celui du vapo craquage se distilleur du
pétrole qu'on utilise aujourd'hui pour
faire les polymères et donc de l'huile
va être intégré dans le vapo cracker au
même titre qu'il peut y avoir des
produits pétroliers en entrée donc vous
voyez bien que là connaître la quantité
de ce qui va être recyclé il y a de
multiples façons de le regarder déjà la
quantité de ce que de l'huile qu'on va
mettre par rapport à la quantité totale
et il faut aussi comprendre que c'est
compliqué parce que les produits
sortants mais c'est pas uniquement des
des molécules qui vont servir à faire
les polymères ça peut être des molécules
qui vous servent à faire du carburant il
y a une autoconsommation sur la chaîne
il y a des pertes etc donc il y a deux
grands principes qui sont un principe de
de conversion et d'allocations et à une
grande méthodologie qui s'appelle la
masse balance avec différentes options
techniques qui sont plus ou moins
favorables on va dire à la transparence
du de la quantité de plastique recyclée
que vous pouvez utiliser alors parmi les
grandes différences mais ce que
j'affecte la quantité de l'huile de
pyrolyse à l'ensemble de mes produits ou
pas et est-ce que je le sur quel pas de
temps je peux le faire et donc est-ce
que je le fais sur l'ensemble d'un
polymère que j'ai dans mon unité de
production qui peut être de polyéthylène
profiter etc donc dans l'esprit je suis
sûr que vous connaissez le système de
des
garanties d'achat en énergie verte quand
vous achetez de l'électricité on vous
dit qu'il y a d'électricité verte avant
que les électrons que vous avez consommé
à la maison sont des électrons qui
viennent du néoliane ne pas nous
photosélectrique etc mais c'est un peu
le même principe c'est à dire c'est un
principe de comptabilité qui permet de
savoir la quantité d'huile de pyrolyse
comment on va la répartir derrière sur
les polymères qu'on va remettre sur le
marché donc ça c'est comme ça par contre
pour que ça fonctionne bien ce que nous
appelons nos vœux c'est que ce calcul
soit fait par un tiers de confiance et
voilà et qu'il soit fait de la manière
la plus rigoureuse pour pas tromper les
utilisateurs des matières recyclées
ensuite il y a une autre recommandation
c'est l'obligation d'incorporation des
matières recyclées des matières
plastiques recyclées donc ça c'est très
évident vous l'imaginez c'est se dire
qu'il faut que la réglementation permet
d'accompagner le recyclage et le faisant
qu'elle fixe des objectifs stricts de
certains nombres d'objectifs vous allez
me dire c'est déjà le cas on les atteint
pas mais parce qu'ils sont globaux mais
on voit bien que sur la bouteille PET ça
a fonctionné donc il faut regarder ce
sujet là et aussi le considérer sous la
forme des des pénalités lorsque les
objectifs ne sont pas atteints on a
quand même un petit sujet de traçabilité
en lien avec le sujet l'avant-dernière
recommandation très rapidement c'est
introduire la notion de recyclage réel
aujourd'hui vous achetez un produit et
écrit recycler recyclable sur
l'emballage le plus souvent sur le
l'emballage ou en tout cas sur le
produit enfin souvent c'est de
l'emballage mais il faudrait se dire que
pourquoi ne pas parler plutôt de
recycler plutôt que de recyclable parce
que là il y a aussi de mon point de vue
de notre point de vue quelque chose qui
peut améliorer le recyclage et puis la
dernière recommandation c'est pour
suivre les consolider les travaux de
recherche nous avons eu la chance hier
je sais pas si vous avez suivi le sujet
d'être avec les chercheurs du GDR
polymère et océan qui avait leur
quatrième journée à Rennes les progrès
sont incroyablesment
c'est significatif quoi les progrès de
connaissances qu'on avait il y a 3 ans
qu'on a terminé le rapport de 2020 trois
ans date anniversaire en terminer les
auditions au même moment et aujourd'hui
il y a des vrais progrès mais il y a
encore des zones d'ombre et notamment
sur des sujets en lien avec le recyclage
avec dernier des derniers articles
scientifiques qui vous montrent qu'il
faudrait regarder précisément
l'évolution d'un certain nombre de
molécules au fur et à mesure des
différents cycles de recyclage avec la
création de molécules qui sont pas
nécessairement très sympathiques donc il
faut regarder le sujet et puis
voilà tous les sujets en lien avec la
santé l'utilisation de recyclage et puis
si quand même un autre sujet de
recherche qui peut être intéressant
c'est normaliser un peu les méthodes de
comparaison des différents types de
recyclage
sous forme assez V ou autre pour pouvoir
vraiment comparer les choses de manière
rigoureuse voilà on en a terminé ce
qu'on voulait vous présenter
donc maintenant c'est à vous de parler
j'espère qu'on vous a pas trop assommé
une question toute bête et un peu naïve
si on suivait l'ensemble de vos
préconisations on pourrait passer de
d'un taux de 10 à combien de 10% de
recyclage de plastique recyclés à quel
pourcentage
je pense la première partie de répondre
qu'on peut vous faire sera jamais sans
que comme c'est les systèmes
technologiques il y a toujours des
pertes et des rendements donc ça c'est
au moins une première réponse à peu près
sûr de
pour imaginer que vu ce que ça demande
comme effort soit il faudrait être
au-delà de 20% en tout cas ce qu'on a
aussi dit et Angèle très clairement
précisé c'est qu'il faut pas imaginer
que le recyclage seul fera l'économie
circulaire et les trois heures n'oubliez
jamais
oui
chardaz des chiens fou alors j'ai
peut-être loupé quelque chose mais
est-ce que vous avez évoqué le fait que
la loi Jacques impose la réduction de
50% du nombre de bouteilles pour
plastique
usage unique mis sur le marché alors je
sais plus quel est l'échéance va être
2030 ou 2035 je crois
est-ce que vous l'avez évoqué ou non
de prévention en la matière
quel est votre position sur la
prévention des bouteilles plastiques moi
je suis assez frappé par un point c'est
que depuis 2005
les pouvoirs publics n'ont plus mené une
seule campagne
incitant les citoyens boire de robinet
plutôt que le long bouteille depuis 2005
en 2005 si si j'ai vérifié en 2005 et
qu'on va là j'avais été sollicité par
l'ADEME pour cofinancer la campagne et
que l'emballage avait refusé
donc effectivement on est d'accord pour
dire que il y a un manque d'information
mais pas que sur ce sujet là par rapport
à tout ce qu'on a mis dans la loi
Jacques et je vais prendre un exemple
que qu'on connaît bien tous les deux
parce que on a légiféré nous-même sur
cette loi qui est que vous avez le droit
quand vous venez vous faire servir à la
découpe de venir avec votre propre
contenant partout au Leclerc le
carrefour n'importe où au magasin bio
vous pouvez faire ça mais personne ne le
dit donc personne ne le sait donc et il
y a également dans la loi le fait que
tout l'émetteur en marché doivent
diminuer aussi leurs emballages
plastiques et ne plus recourir aux
emballages jetables donc ça c'est aussi
présent pour l'instant on n'en suis pas
le chemin et très clairement ce qu'on a
peut-être oublié quand on a légiféré
c'est de dire qui devait faire
l'information mais ça moi je m'en
souviens maintenant je m'en souviendrai
pour les prochaines fois de bien
mentionner qui doit faire l'information
sur ce sujet et notamment sur lui ce que
vous avez dit sur l'utilisation de de
l'eau du robinet plutôt que de l'eau en
bouteille effectivement il nous faut
peut-être l'inscrire quelque part qui
doit et peut-être l'État ou les
collectivités ou je ne sais pas qui mais
en tout cas il faut absolument le faire
et on a plein de dispositifs qui sont
déjà dans la loi pour le propre les le
fait que vous puissiez apporter votre
propre contenant c'est effectif depuis
le 1er janvier 2023 non le 1er janvier
pardon de l'année dernière donc ça ne se
met pas en place parce que personne ne
le sait et personne ne communique c'est
dommage parce que on a déjà légéré
peut-être pas suffisamment pour réduire
mais on l'a fait et bon voilà on a déjà
interpellé le gouvernement à ce sujet
pour demander à ce que l'information
soit faite voilà
que oui il y avait une réflexion là
dessus moi c'est des services des
ministres que j'ai pu avoir et
qu'effectivement il faudrait le faire
mais pour l'instant rien n'est fait donc
peut-être qu'on aurait dû mettre dans la
loi que c'était au magasin eux-mêmes de
mettre vous pouvez venir avec votre
propre contenant nous vous servirons et
effectivement quand on le fait quand on
y va avec son propre contenant on se
heurte à des des vendeurs et des
vendeuses qui nous disent ah maintenant
c'est pas possible j'ai pas le droit de
faire ça donc c'est un sujet et sur
l'eau du robinet par rapport au
bouteilles et sur les objectifs qu'on a
de diminuer oui ils sont là les
objectifs mais comme vous dites rien
n'est vraiment mis en place pour
l'éviter et notamment avec ce qu'on
cette consigne pour
qui n'est pas une consigne pour réemploi
qui est une fausse consigne en fait ben
on a bien vu en Allemagne ils ont mis ça
alors ils ont un retour un bon retour
des bouteilles mais le nombre de
bouteilles à
augmenter donc c'est pas une bonne chose
en fait pour réduire le recours à la
bouteille plastique donc voilà je
rajouterais sur le les actions quand
même qui ont été conduites je vais faire
référence à la loi egalim donc on est en
2018 lors des débats on avait quand même
introduit l'interdiction d'utilisation
des bouteilles plastiques dans la
restauration collective colère et voilà
donc le débat avait quand même eu lieu
sous l'angle de avec des éléments de
débat qui était on a quand même une eau
du du robinet qui est correct on a le
sujet de l'utilisation massive des
bouteilles plastiques on avait quand
même réussi cette avancée là et on a mis
dans la loi je pense c'était la loi
climat et résilience et les fontaines
les fontaines qui doivent et qui ne sont
pas encore installés dans les lieux qui
reçoivent du public
c'est ça et voilà donc là aussi il va
nous falloir encore interpellé
concernant les concernant les la
réduction de moitié des bouteilles à
usage unique mais sur le marché dans le
plan national de prévention des déchets
qui a été publié récemment avec je crois
deux ans de retard il n'y a rien sur
cette aspect là strictement rien j'ai
interrogé les grands les trois grands
metteurs en marché de bouteilles Nestlé
coca et Danone aucun de m'a répondu en
fait ils ont rien prévu en gros
ils en ont rien à
donc il nous faut interpeller nous nous
dans nos commissions nous faisons un
contrôle de l'évaluation de
l'application de la loi et donc voilà
après on fait des remontées sur le
manque de décret sorti ou de
d'application donc on le fait remonter
nous parce qu'on a chacun dans nos
commissions respectives dans nos
assemblées la possibilité de le faire et
on le fait en déplorant que certains
décrets ne sont toujours pas pris ont du
retard et que certains sujets tu
pourrais citer ce qui est dans la loi
âgée que sur la possibilité pour les
citoyens d'interpeller que l'article 72
si j'ai beau de mémoire ou 60
[Musique]
environnement vous avez évoqué la masse
balance je sais que c'est un sujet qui
est très technique
en gros vous avez dit qu'il fallait
qu'il y a un tiers de confiance qui
contrôle en entrée en sortie le puis ce
qui se passe dans le vapo cracker mais
sur le sujet de la location en elle-même
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'on dise je mets
10 en entrée
je m'y admettons 10% d'huile d'huile de
pyrolyse sur 100 en sortie il y a quoi
je l'attribue à ce que je l'attribue
simplement au polyo les fines ou est-ce
que je l'attribue à tout ce qui sort de
mon vapo cracker c'est pas exactement le
même calcul est-ce que vous avez un
point de vue sur justement cette
attribution comment elle devrait être
faite le point de vue que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que le mieux
même ne serait-ce que par rapport à la
référence qu'on peut avoir en cyclage
mécanique ou là c'est évident c'est
d'être le se contenter de regarder
l'affectation sur les parties sortantes
du vapo cracker qui sont utilisés pour
faire des molécules parce que c'était
l'objet c'est-à-dire que vous dit dans
le cycle chimique c'est celui de des
polymérisation
alors après c'est oui je vois ce que
voulait dire il y a une stratégie ou en
tant qu'industriel je dis que l'ensemble
de l'huile de pyrolyse que j'ai mis dans
mon vapo cracker je la retrouve dans mes
polyo les fines enfin mes plastiques
donc à partir de là je j'ai un taux de
matière recyclée qui est important où il
y a une stratégie qui est de dire j'ai
pas les polluerines ne représentent que
10% de ma production donc je n'ai que 1%
de polyester dans le cyclés
d'un côté je peux monter à 100% de
l'autre côté je peux monter à 1 enfin
pour faire simple
vous dire j'en ai 25 % 30 % etc et dans
les électrons que vous consommez là ça
peut être 1% en référence à la logique
que vous venez de nous présenter
et après ce que je peux rajouter par
rapport à ça c'est que pour les citoyens
enfin pour tous les citoyens ça va être
compliqué de comprendre et la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est que vont-ils
penser quand ils vont découvrir cette
espèce de calcul complexe alors que
très concrètement ils vont croire en
voyant affiché un pourcentage de recyclé
que c'est effectivement le cas ce qui ne
sera peut-être pas
parce que vous voyez aujourd'hui on est
à neuf on l'a dit c'est pour aller me
faire beaucoup cracker quelque soit la
méthode utilisée du 7 ou du 6 voilà
après il y a des logiques mais en fait
la méthode qui me semble la meilleure
c'est celle qui est importe le plus de
transparence celle qui porte le plus de
confiance celles qui traduit le mieux
parce qu'elle va permettre comme
potentiel cette technologie là
on les compte pour les poliers et les
filles et puis pour autre chose c'est
surtout ça à la limite ensuite qui
l'attribue au polyoléfine ou un autre
résine enfin personnellement je m'en
fiche un peu qu'est-ce qui est important
c'est quelle est la masse réellement
recyclée en masse
il y a peut-être des questions en ligne
bonjour
je suis juste un petit pas de côté sur
la publication du 5e rapport du Haut
Conseil pour le climat on parlait des
émissions liées au plastique tout à
l'heure qui date un peu un constat un
peu sévère sur une France qui est pas
prête et sur un gouvernement qui devrait
accélérer de manière drastique je sais
pas si vous quel regard vous portez sur
ce constat si vous le trouvez vous aussi
un peu sévère aussi effectivement on y
est pas encore
je l'entends
au défi le mur des filles qu'on a devant
nous on peut se poser des questions sur
le les petites avancées que nous avons
tenues jusqu'à présent et sur le fait
que on voit bien pour avoir fait le
rapport sur la pollution plastique déjà
il y a quasiment 4 ans
on mesure que le chemin est long
finalement pour l'amélioration puisque
voilà on n'a pas vraiment résolu le
problème des déchets mais c'est aussi ce
qu'on avait vu venir c'est à dire que
tant qu'on fait pas une qu'on mène pas
une réduction drastique de de l'usage
des plastiques et notamment des
plastiques à usage unique tant qu'on
revoit pas plein de choses sur les
additifs sur les polymères divers et
variés qu'on utilise je vais vous citer
un exemple les pots de yaourts en
polystyrène donc on n'a pas d'unité de
recyclage en France donc un pot de
yaourt en polystyrène si vous le mettez
dans votre sac de tri il va faire des
kilomètres et éventuellement si les
recyclé pour aller en Espagne en
Belgique donc la question pour moi c'est
la question du sens qu'on peut donner à
tout ça voilà et ça reste entier c'est à
dire que les peaux de yaourt sont
toujours en polystyrène même si il y a
eu une loi une proposition de loi qui a
été votée à l'Assemblée nationale qui
est pas encore qui a pas encore été
examiné au Sénat qui a essayé de voilà
de contrôler un petit peu tout ça et on
en est pas là donc les industriels qui
ont mis ces produits là sur le marché
sans anticiper parce que il y a quelques
années on ne parlait pas du cycle de vie
et on envisage on envisageait pas du
tout la fin de vie c'était pas un
problème donc voilà on enfouille encore
beaucoup de nos ordures ménagères et il
y a dans les années 70 tout partait dans
les sacs plastiques étaient enfouis donc
là on a effectivement évolué puisque on
le fait différemment n'empêche que on
reste avec l'héritage de tout se laisser
faire qui était pas vraiment à laisser
faire en toute connaissance de cause
c'est maintenant qu'on sait que on a un
gros sujet avec les déchets et que pour
l'instant on n'est pas arrivé à endiguer
ce flux qui ne fait que grossir de nos
déchets
sémantique c'est pas juste un trait
d'humour c'est une réalité par rapport à
ce qu'elle dit Angèle elle dit
aujourd'hui on dispose pas d'unité de
recyclage du pot de yaourt en France moi
je vous dirais qu'aujourd'hui on ne
dispose pas d'unités de déscyclage des
potirons en France
parce qu'en fait le polystyrène qui est
qui va dans une usine de recyclage c'est
pas ne servira pas à refaire des pots de
yaourts mais à faire des cintres et des
peaux
alimentaires c'est-à-dire on peut y
mettre des aliments mais quand il sera
recyclé ce polystyrène il l'aura pas et
donc il servira à faire des objets dont
on peut se demander si c'est vraiment
utile les pots de fleurs et les cintres
[Musique]
en quoi
en plastique
elles sont pas vous le dire sauf
exception elles sont pas recycle en
plastique cette notion de cyclage
excusez-moi je sors un peu de mon rôle
mais cette notion de des cyclage qui est
popularisée par Madame Gontard qui ont
fait ces shugueras et qui vend des
bouquins avec on peut l'appliquer à tous
les matériaux elle est pas propre au
plastique
c'est pas parce que je recycle un pot de
yaourt en cintre que pour autant ce
recyclage n'est pas vertueux le cintre
il y aura beaucoup plus longtemps qu'on
peut dire yaourt voilà
peut-être mais je rappelle quand même
pour ce qui est des objets en plastique
qu'un cintre en plastique vous en avez
déjà fait l'expérience il casse et qu'on
ne peut pas le réparer c'est quand même
matière particulière c'est à dire
oui alors ça dépend
un cintre en bois ou en métal on peut le
réparer mais un cintre en plastique non
derrière ce débat il y a le l'objet même
qu'on associe à l'économie circulaire de
dire que cette boucle qui tourne c'est
juste ça qu'on veut souligner en disant
ça c'est pour pas tromper parce que
aussi vous avez des nous nous sommes
avertis dans cette salle vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui croient que le
recyclage chez magique il croit parce
qu'il voit sur un emballage recyclable
c'est tout tout va bien etc c'est
essayer d'être le plus précis le plus
factuel comme vous l'avez fait le plus
souvent possible pour faire comprendre
aux gens les limites des systèmes et que
même contribue à l'évolution de ces
systèmes là en appelant des choses plus
plus en cohérence avec ce que le système
voudrait porter alors qu'il ne porte que
partiellement
en circuit fermé le carton brun un peu
mais nous cartons brun par exemple
l'autre marotte de Madame Gontard c'est
que le plastique il y a un nombre limité
de cycles de recyclage ce qui est pas
faux mais le papier aussi
papier carton aussi parce que les fibres
se raccourcis c'est qu'au bout d'un
moment vous perdez une partie des fibres
etc donc tout ça n'est pas propre au
plastique motard qui travaille sur les
biopolymères passent son temps à casser
du sucre aussi je veux dire sur le
plastique avec des arguments qui sont
pas toujours très scientifiques sans
rentrer dans la police mais par rapport
au plastique il y a autre chose il y a
une petite différence c'est sur la
pollution que transporte les matières
plastiques comme je l'ai dit les
additifs qui sont relargués en continu
le fait que un plastique qui se retrouve
dans la nature se couvre d'un biophile
et comme le plastique ne se décompose
pas va rester sur l'océan pendant des
dizaines des centaines d'années et va
véhiculer va déjà capter tous les tous
les polluants que qui va rencontrer
parce que c'est hydrophobe va se couvrir
d'un biophile et va transporter des
bactéries des virus partout donc c'est
différent de des autres matières c'est
cet aspect il ne faut jamais l'oublier
le plastique à est très différent des
autres matières sur ce sujet là puisque
ne se décompose pas il est colonisé il
est voilà et il a il absorbe en fait
tous les polluants qu'il rencontre
voilà en grande partie
comment on fait pour savoir s'il y a des
questions en ligne
et oui parce qu'on en a pas vu
oui une autre question à propos de la
des formulations chimiques des
plastiques
qui est fondamental puisque il y a je
sais pas combien de milliers ou de
dizaines de milliers
et donc de type de plastique on ne sait
pas plein de combinaisons on ne sait pas
et est-ce qu'on pourrait par avoir un
label mettre sur les paquets en
plastique dire voilà c'est du plastique
dont on ne connaît pas la composition
parce que c'est quand même aussi une
question fondamentale de savoir ce qu'il
y a dedans c'est à dire que le
consommateur ne sait pas le type
d'additif qui est utilisé si ça peut
être ou pas un additif nocif pour la
santé si ça peut être un perturbateur
endocrinien ou autre chose et c'est en
ça que c'est quand même fondamentalement
différent du bois ou fondamentalement
différent du papier ou fondamentalement
différent de l'acier ou d'autres
d'autres matériaux sauf quand le bois
est couvert de de vernis et là aussi il
y a un problème avec avec ces matières
là effectivement mais pour l'instant
c'est un impensé on n'a pas tellement
réfléchi parce qu'on pensait que le
plastique c'était très bien ça ne
bougeait pas et très clairement dans les
dernières années il y avait aucun
problème avec le plastique et maintenant
on commence à voir que les problèmes
sont variés comme je vous l'ai dit avec
le relargage des des additifs qui se
fait en continu notamment des talades
qui sont comme vous l'avez dit des
perturbateurs endocriniens qui sortent
des sols plastiques par exemple et quand
on avait fait le rapport sur la
pollution plastique moi je ne comprenais
pas comment c'était possible si en fait
c'est il y a une charge qui est
tellement importante en stalate c'est un
assouplissant c'est donc ça c'est pour
que le sol plastique soit bien souple
d'ailleurs quand il est très très vieux
le sol plastique bah il casse parce
qu'il a plu il est à lattes donc c'est à
lattes sont relarguées en permanence
sous forme de poudre que vous ne voyez
même pas et en marchant dessus vous
soulevez et vous allez en manger vous
allez en respirer donc on a on est
soumis et là il y a des études qui le
montrent à entité de Stala très
importante qu'on va éliminer mais à
force on peut aussi se poser la question
si on en a en continu comme ça est-ce
que ça va pas avoir un impact sur notre
santé un perturbateur endocrinien c'est
une c'est une molécule qui agit comme
une hormone sur sur l'organisme donc
très petite quantité gros effets donc
c'est un sujet donc voilà le sujet des
plastiques est vraiment très large et
voilà sur la simplification je
rajouterai que je vais faire référence à
la façon qu'on a travaillé à l'OPEX vous
savez que nos rapports sont le fruit de
d'audition de scientifiques et d'experts
sur les sujets sur lesquels on travaille
et bien et on voit apparaître d'ailleurs
je suis persuadé que tu le sens comme
moi depuis 2020 2021 2022 on voit
apparaît des sujets nouveaux et ce sujet
de la simplification du nombre de
polymères de la simplification du nombre
d'additifs etc il est porté lui-même par
les chercheurs quand les croise qui nous
au travers des solutions et des
perspectives qui nous mettent en
évidence on sent que c'est apparu et
alors que ça n'était pas le cas du tout
2020 et on voit aujourd'hui qu'il
apparaît et il a même été l'objet de
quelques débats durant le traité
international qui serait déroulée on
sent que c'est un sujet qui monte voilà
et c'est un sujet sur au traité
international qui est voilà dans le
cadre de
l'ONU qui a eu lieu à Paris il y a pas
longtemps où on était avec Philippe on a
vu le sujet monter en flèche et quelque
part tout le monde s'accorde à dire
qu'il faut réglementer mais pour dire
qu'il faudrait encore des études
scientifiques supplémentaires donc
vraisemblablement pour prendre encore du
temps avant de pouvoir décider de
manière conjointe parce qu'évidemment il
faudrait que ça se fasse de façon
internationale sur les substances qu'on
va garder ou pas
donc c'est un sujet qui maintenant est
bien compris par tout le monde et on va
s'y pencher
peut-être jusqu'à découvrir que on aura
peut-être quelques impasses c'est-à-dire
que peut-être que certaines substances
si on ne l'aimait pas on n'aura pas les
mêmes
[Musique]
usages du plastique parce qu'on aura
plus les qualités qu'on avait avant bon
voilà bon on pourra trouver des
alternatives donc le sujet est ouvert
dès que vous voulez simplifier de cette
façon là il va falloir si ça doit se
traduire sous forme législative c'est à
dire ça va être l'objet de liste c'est
listes doit être positive elle doit être
négative est-ce qu'on nous dit ce qu'on
autorise ou est-ce qu'on écrit ce qu'on
interdit et à partir de là on arrive
tout de suite dans quelque chose qui est
une limite forte c'est tu le dis des
affaires le secret des affaires et la
place du du de la liberté d'entreprendre
dans la Constitution
oui
sur les plastiques et un peu au-delà
parce que c'est je trouve que c'est un
peu ce qui transparaît de nous échanges
tout à l'heure est-ce que vous avez pas
un peu des fois l'impression d'être un
peu impuissant je prends la question des
fontaines à vous disiez oui on contrôle
l'action du Gouvernement vérifie que les
textes d'applications sont publiés etc
sur les fontaines il y a pas besoin de
l'application la question c'est qu'il y
a pas de contrôle les contrôles ils sont
la diligence du gouvernement je prends
un autre sujet qui est en dehors des
plastiques mais qui dit bien que dans
les choses se passent obligation de
trier la source des lieux déchets pour
tous les producteurs professionnels je
demande à des préfectures vous pouvez me
dire combien vous avez fait de contrôle
et quel est les résultats de si on
contrôle ils sont incapables de me
donner un seul chiffre ce qui veut dire
qu'ils ne font pas un seul contrôle ça
quel est le pouvoir du Parlement
vis-à-vis de cette résistance là du
gouvernement je reprends l'exemple du
plan national de prévention des déchets
c'est le gouvernement qui le fait tout
seul et la question de la réduction de
moitié des bouteilles plastiques le
figure pas qu'en plus ça fait pourrir à
l'état français le risque en plus de
sanctions parfois internationales
Commission européenne etc est-ce que
vous avez pas un sentiment d'impuissance
par rapport à cette espèce d'inertie de
l'appareil d'État
qui fait en groupe je vois ce qu'il veut
il y a certains jours effectivement ça
peut paraître un peu frustrant et la
réponse que je vais vous faire c'est pas
une réponse de la note scientifique
qu'on remet c'est pas un sujet qu'on a
évoqué avec les gens qu'on a auditionné
qu'on a croisé entre nous c'est ma
réponse personnelle la réponse
personnelle et que nous avons de rôle
voter des lois et contrôler l'action du
gouvernement que moi je traduis
différemment c'est évaluer les
politiques publiques et des lois que
nous votons le SAV le service
après-vente et c'est regarder
aujourd'hui lorsque nous votons une loi
en se contente de comptabiliser le
nombre de décrets qui ont été pris par
rapport au décret qu'il devait être pris
pour moi c'est pas de l'évaluation
l'évaluation c'est de regarder
l'efficacité c'est de regarder
l'efficience c'est de regarder
l'effectivité c'est de regarder les
impacts directs indirects attendu
inattendu
[Musique]
imaginez ou non imaginer enfin voilà
toutes ces choses là doivent faire
partie donc je suis de ceux qui militent
pour que les parlementaires évaluent
davantage et légifères un peu moins
c'est ma réponse personnelle et en
faisant ça je lève le sentiment
d'impuissance que vous auriez pu ce qui
c'est je suis d'accord aussi mais nous
enfin on est en agile on est dans
l'action et rencontre très
fourni avec les ministres et on les
interpelle ou avec les services et donc
on le dit et on le redit alors bien
évidemment bon on le fait on espère
toujours qu'on va obtenir globalement on
espère que les choses vont avancer un
petit peu plus rapidement sur cette
fameuse loi Haget notamment ou même la
loi climat est résilience et on compte
aussi sur la société civile un petit peu
pour être appuyée parce que c'est bien
nous en tant que parlementaire et
législateur on met des choses dans la
loi mais évidemment tout seul on ne peut
pas peut-être tout faire et il y a
également tout le pouvoir de la société
civile qui peut aussi par les
associations
appuyées et puis faire en sorte que il y
a une pression pour l'application c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe pour les
fontaines parce qu'il y a une
bien sûr la presse évidemment vous allez
vous avez un pouvoir enfin vous savez
immense celui de communiquer et puis
d'être voilà et peut-être le pouvoir
qu'on a pas nous donc bien sûr on compte
sur vous
c'est très important et pour une fois
sur des sur des ah oui pardon sur des
sujets qui sont les bons sujets
tout à l'heure que les progrès étaient
significatifs bon il y avait encore des
hommes d'ombres mais vous parlez de
progrès technologiques vous avez raison
de me demander de préciser j'étais
imprécie et dans une autre scientifique
de l'Office pardonne pas d'être imprécie
vous le j'en suis voilà merci de ce
rappel à l'ordre c'est les progrès dans
les connaissances scientifiques c'est
les progrès sur les mécanismes de
vieillissement des plastiques par
exemple c'est à dire qu'à l'époque en
2020 je me souviens qu'il y avait des
termes fragmentation utilisaient pas et
alors que hier ils ont clairement dit
qu'ils ont regardé les choses sur les
mécanismes de vieillissement l'érosion
de surface etc donc on comprend mieux
aujourd'hui comment un objet perdu dans
la nature va se transformer en
micro-particules c'est un exemple mais
il y a aussi des milieux qui étaient pas
observés à l'époque on a vous savez la
pollution plastique elle est fortement
liée à la pollution marine l'image du
continent de plastique l'image de la
tortue
dans son filet malheureusement donc
c'est le milieu marin mais aujourd'hui
on a des recherches qui vous permettent
de voir qu'un atmosphère de comprendre
les mécanismes atmosphériques de voir
qu'il y en a au des montagnes dans l'eau
douce enfin voilà c'est la connaissance
scientifique qui a considérablement
progressé sur des zones d'ombre que nous
nous avions identifié en 2020 qui
aujourd'hui sont levés mais comme la
connaissance scientifique vous savez
c'est pas là pour le coup c'est pas
circulaire c'est c'est linéaire avec
l'infini à rejoindre et bien il y a
toujours une connaissance nouvelle en
appel une nouvelle à obtenir donc il y a
encore aujourd'hui nous disait on a des
résultats nouveaux qu'on n'avait pas à
l'époque mais on a encore des
incertitudes à lever et voilà et c'est
ce que je voulais vous dire en disant
qu'il y avait eu des des gains
importants parce que hier nous étions
avec le GDR donc le groupement de
recherche polymère océan que des
chercheurs on était pas sur des sujets
technologiques
justement est-ce que il y a eu les seuls
progrès qu'il y a eu c'était sur le
recyclage chimique
c'est la nouveauté dans le dans le
paysage
mécanique également c'est beaucoup
amélioré il y a aussi la l'utilisation
des enzymes telle le carbuieuse mais ça
existe déjà en 2020 c'est pas c'est pas
tellement nouveau si alors si il y a un
mot qu'on a pas cité ça c'est pas bien
du tout aussi il y a des choses des
progrès qui arrivent avec
l'éco-conception et ce qui est de plus
en plus dans l'air du temps et dans les
choses à défendre c'est de se dire
l'éco-conception et aussi un levier pour
permettre d'améliorer le recyclage parce
que quand je suis aujourd'hui avec des
plastiques multicouches que je peux pas
recycler si demain par l'écho conception
j'arrive à les produire différemment et
qu'ils apportent les mêmes fonctions de
protection des aliments par exemple qui
sont plus facilement recyclés recyclable
donc voilà l'éco-conception est un
facteur il y a le recyclage chimique il
y a aussi l'éco-conception qui doit être
collaborative et partenariale c'est à
dire que c'est pas on passe pas du
marketing à l'éco-conception en disant
je vais juste faire un toilettage au
niveau de mon entreprise je fais une
éco-conception partenariale où je fais
venir autour de la table le fabricant du
polymère l'utilisateur de mon produit
les co-organismes l'entreprise qui va
recycler mon produit mais sous-traitants
pourquoi pas les pouvoirs publics et
donc je construis un polymère j'ai
co-construit un gecko qu'on soit un
produit en tenant compte de toutes les
les
fringues donc on a évoqué et qui doivent
être levés et voilà donc
l'éco-conception est un formidable
levier de de progrès de progrès même si
et c'est très bien parce que beaucoup
d'entreprises se lancent dans cette
conception mais lors de nos déplacements
notamment nous avons découvert quelques
petits autres problèmes à savoir que par
exemple des bouteilles sont des
bouteilles de boisson sont mises sur le
marché avec un manchon un manchon c'est
à dire une couverture
une enveloppe plastique qui n'est pas
constituée de la même matière que la
bouteille et qui donc gêne le tri et
donc puisque ces metteurs en marché ont
mis cette espèce de manchon très colorée
qu'ils ont mis exprès autour pour la
vente en fait pour le marketing et bien
il paye donc une taxe une écho necotaxe
supplémentaire à cause de cela et bien
ils le font parce que de toute façon au
niveau marketing il s'en sortent mieux
alors que ça ne pourra pas être bien
repéré dans les sur les tapis de tri à
cause de ce manchon qui induit en erreur
donc voilà donc on a tout ça c'est pour
ça que c'est très complexe tout se
développements parce que ça heurte enfin
ça se croise avec et bien voilà
l'émetteur en marché qui veulent faire
du chiffre qui vendent qui veulent
vendre plus et qui donc avec ce manchon
de boissons de jus d'orange etc qui est
entièrement tout plein de couleurs et
qui va visiblement être mieux vendu
qu'une autre bouteille qui sera plus
vertueuse donc voilà c'est là aussi on a
je voulais dire ce voilà cette chose là
pour dire que c'est pas si simple que
cela il y a un autre exemple qui
révélateur de la vérité d'un jour n'est
pas celle du lendemain c'est je vais
vous parler d'une éco-conception qui
était celle de fabriquer des bouteilles
plus légères donc on a fait ça on a
réduit la quantité de plastique qu'on a
consommé et aujourd'hui on a un nouvel
idée en tête c'est de se dire on va
utiliser ces bouteilles pour faire de la
consigne pour réemploi mais on les a
créé de façon tellement légère qu'on
peut pas les réemployer et on se rend
compte que ce niveau-là il faut une
autre éco-conception qu'il faut que des
bouteilles plus rigides etc et donc du
coup en affronte des objectifs qu'on
s'est fixés de limitation de quantité on
revient sur la logique qui était celle
de réduction donc tout ça pour vous dire
qu'il faut aussi prendre le sujet et
humilité toute sa complexité fait que et
bien voilà c'est nous tirons des
constats des conclusions mais le passage
à l'action parfois au niveau économique
il est plus compliqué
alors justement vous attendez quels
effets de votre rapport
et bien notre rapport il est destiné
d'abord aux autres parlementaires donc
c'est donner de la connaissance à nos
collègues de façon à légiférer de
manière plus éclairée mais bien
évidemment on va le diffuser également
auprès de dans ta circonscription dans
mon département de manière à ce que tout
le monde soit un petit peu plus au fait
de de la problématique du recyclage ou
de du recyclage tel qu'il nous est vendu
ou proposé et avec comme vous l'avez vu
toute la complexité qui va avec ce sujet
qui n'est pas résolu encore avec des
objectifs qu'on n'a pas atteint et
visiblement qu'on n'est pas prêt
d'atteindre non plus voilà
alors moi ce que je Jonathan et bien
c'est presque ce qu'on a eu avec le
précédent rapport de 2020 c'est à dire
qu'on sache effectivement le faire vivre
le présenter auprès de tous les acteurs
concernés elle est en discuter avec le
ministre pour lui dire voilà ce que nous
on a vu on lui présentera et finalement
le faire vivre pour que on continue à
nous-même à rencontrer des acteurs de du
sujet du plastique soit des industriels
que soit des pouvoirs publics que ce
soit des ONG que ce soit des
établissements scolaires enfin tous les
acteurs concernés pour continuer à
progresser dans le suivi des évolutions
et être au rendez-vous de ces évolutions
et puis peut-être d'un prochain travail
il y aura un nouveau sujet à regarder
avec attention mais de pas lâcher pour
de rien lâcher sur ce sujet là pour
continuer à dire ce qu'on a à dire de la
place qu'elle a notre voilà ce que j'en
attends
donc c'est à nous de le faire vivre plus
que de poser sur une table et d'attendre
que vivre
il y a pas de question en ligne
voilà donc s'il y a plus de questions ça
veut dire qu'on a épuisé le sujet pas du
recyclage mais de sujets de la note
bon ben merci à toutes et à tous
très bien